when you got the audition for saturday
night live they said
do not do your character marry catherine
gallagher
who the [ __ ] gave you that it was so
dumb i don't want to say her name she
she was kind of out in la
and she was there during that period
where
there was just a little bit of a low
there we're not quite as strong of women
they've been amazing women before that
but this was a little bit of a low
period i thought she was in la and she
called herself the unofficial talent
scout but she wasn't really i don't
think it was really official and she was
much more interested in comedy boys and
i was like she's missing all the good
girls and and yes so then marcy klein
got involved and she marcy klein
all right she is uh calvin klein's
daughter and she's worked at uh saturday
night live forever yes forever she
had heard about you
from someone
and she said uh submitted tape and i'll
take a look at it i'll get it to lauren
and you said no you need to see me live
in a club when i do marry kathryn
gallagher you'll get turned on by this
you stuck to your guns and she came out
and saw you right she came out and saw
me yes because five years before that i
had an audition they asked for a tape of
five characters and i spent all my
waitressing money making my tape and i
got passed over and i remember being on
a pay phone outside of my apartment in
hollywood on the corner of fountain and
vine across the nail polio logo and i
found out they were they weren't gonna
have me they weren't gonna see me i
cried and cried but then i thought you
know what i'm just going to work really
hard on my show create characters work
write write perform so that when they
come back again i'm going to be like
locked and loaded and ready and then
sure enough they came back five years
later and i was like they when they
asked for that tape i was like i'm not
giving you a tape you got to see the
live show and yeah so marcy flew out to
see that and it went great and then she
was like you're coming to audition for
saturday night live and i was like yes
and in the audition
you did marry
no
yeah she got kind of jealous and got
wind that i was flying to new york to
audition right and she's like yeah
whatever that was your strongest
character that was your strongest
character
did marcy say to you afterwards why
didn't you do mary katherine gallagher
no she was just kind of letting me do
whatever i wanted to do
so she didn't care but then when i when
i did do that at the at saturday night
live i even had a hard time there like i
told
a writer i said i have this character
that i do and i want to get on the show
and he read it and kind of read it over
and he goes ah the reason this can't
work is that's not really a joke and
that's not going to work
nah this thing
this is not going to work and i was like
no no i know i do it in my show it works
and then i went to this guy steve corn
he was like just tell me what you're
doing your show and we'll type it up you
know on paper if you read it
it's something you got to see in other
words to write down oh this girl in a
catholic school uniform is going to come
out and fall down
that's just not
funny yeah i get that so we read it at
the table but lauren does know so the
first time we read at the table he was
like oh this is good he he knew he was
like i want to wait let's wait and do it
next week with gabriel byrne and i was
so excited so then it did get picked for
the show but then um you know they do a
dress show before the live show on
saturday and
uh the dress show order mary catherine
was at the bottom and i was like what
they must not oh no and the stuff that's
at the bottom is usually going to get
cut they don't believe in it right we
ended up not even rehearsing it on
saturday because they ran out of time it
was dinner break they're like sorry and
they just do kind of a walk through
rehearsal and i was so mad i thought
they're not getting what this is i think
because when you're just reading at the
table you're reading stage direction she
falls into chairs she does in other
words they've got you at the bottom of
the list which indicates to you that
it's probably gonna get cut it sucks
that they don't get it they don't
believe in it yeah or or
yeah i'm thinking they're not knowing
what how physical this is and you know i
i'm like i'm gonna have to i'm gonna
have to do it i'm gonna have to [ __ ]
show them and i'm gonna blow the roof
off the house you know so i did that
dress rehearsal and i was like
my heart was pounding and i remember
it's like five four three two
and i went on there and i just had to
show them and i did it and i you know
had the skirt i lifted my leg up and i
did gymnastics and i sang and i did a
monologue and i threw myself into those
chairs and
then it killed and it killed and then i
went into lauren michael's office
between dress and arrows all the casts
goes in you go in and look at his
bulletin board to see what's making it
to the live show and my sketch mary
catholic gallagher got moved from the
bottom of the show to the top and i was
like oh wow